Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Di cosa si parla a un evento come questo?
Certo, vi potrei parlare
del perché la gente
usa Facebook, o Google,
cosa c'è di bello al giorno
d'oggi, le solite cose.
Ma voglio parlare invece
di questo quadro,
o meglio del titolo di questo quadro.
È un quadro di Gauguin,
che si intitola "Da dove veniamo,
chi siamo, dove andiamo"
È proprio di questo che vi voglio parlare:
è facile parlare di Google, Facebook,
nuove tecnologie,
però si può dire qualcosa di più,
cioè qual è stato il nostro passato
e soprattutto
dov'è che stiamo andando,
in quale direzione stiamo andando.
Allora per far questo vi introduco
a un bellissimo libro che secondo
me vale la pena di leggere,
che si chiama 'Flatland',
un romanzo di molte dimensioni,
che è anche stato tradotto in italiano
per cui lo trovate in varie edizioni.
Racconto fantastico a più dimensioni.
Allora, 'Flatland' letteralmente
è la terra piatta,
e il mondo che racconta questo romanzo
è come un quadro di
Mondrian, essenzialmente.
Gli abitanti sono dei poligoni,
sono esseri piatti: sono triangoli,
quadrati e così via.
E qui vedete una bella foto
istantanea di famiglia,
degli abitanti di questo mondo
un po' strano, un po' speciale.
C'è una gerarchia, tanto
per invogliarvi un po' a leggerlo,
e vi assicuro che è
un romanzo molto -
favenire molte idee,
veramente tantissime.
C'era all'epoca di Tesla,
anche, tra l'altro.
La gerarchia sociale:
chi ha il corno più aguzzo
è più pericoloso, ok?
Per cui quei triangoli sono pericolosi:
più il triangolo è aguzzo
e più è pericoloso.
Le donne in questo mondo sono linee.
Per cui potete capire la pericolosità.
È anche un romanzo di satira
per cui, insomma,
è carino da leggere oltre che
scientificamente valido.
Qui vedete un'altra istantanea
della casa di uno di questi abitanti, ok?
È una terra piatta e non
sorprendentemente tutto è piatto:
qui vedete due triangoli
che si stringono la mano,
qui lo lascio alla vostra
immaginazione, cioè non dico altro,
le parole non servono.
Allora, il protagonista di questo
romanzo è un quadrato
che narra le sue avventure
in questa terra piatta.
A un certo momento, vi dico
la trama in dieci secondi,
incontra una sfera
che vive in un mondo
con una dimensione in più,
vive a tre dimensioni
e per cui viene illuminato
da questo concetto
che c'è qualcosa di più oltre al
suo mondo a due dimensioni
e vi lascio la suspence
perché poi la trama si evolve
in maniera abbastanza interessante.
Quello che ci interessa,
oltre a quello che ci può dire,
è l'introduzione, per esempio:
'Agli abitanti dello spazio in generale,
questo lavoro è dedicato
da un umile nativo di Flatland
nella speranza che,
come io sono stato iniziato
ai misteri delle tre dimensioni,
essendo stato precedentemente
abituato solo a due,
così i cittadini di
questa regione celestiale
possano aspirare a cose sempre più alte,
ai segreti delle quattro,
cinque e anche sei dimensioni,
così contribuendo
all'allargamento dell'immaginazione
tra le razze superiori
dell'umanitàsolida.
Non so voi, ma [secondo me]
ha una bella considerazione di noi, no?
Cioè noi siamo la 'razza
superiore dell'umanitàsolida'
rispetto a questi 'esseri piatti'.
La Esse di Superman non sta
per Superman, sta per solido.
Per cui sentite che il nostro ego
è pompato, da questa cosa.
Bene, sì - mica tanto,
perché dove viviamo?
In un mondo a tre dimensioni, lo sappiamo:
però già ancora nel terzo secolo,
personaggi come Lattanzio,
filosofo, retorico e quant'altro,
scrive questa cosa:
'Qualcuno di buon senso
crede che ci siano uomini
i cui piedi siano più in alto
delle loro teste?
Che il grano e gli alberi
crescano verso il basso?
Che la pioggia e la neve
e la grandine cadano verso l'alto?
Io resto senza parole verso coloro che
avendo sbagliato una volta
perseverano nella loro follia
e difendono una cosa vana con un'altra.'
Di cosa sta parlando Lattanzio?
Del fatto che la Terra non sia piatta.
Ma chi può essere così pazzo da pensare
che la Terra non è piatta?
E perché?
Perché bastava guardarsi
attorno, all'epoca:
com'è la Terra? Piatta!
Piatta nella nostra 'bolla', per lo meno.
Poi si è capito
che la Terra non era piatta,
quando si è cominciato
a viaggiare su larghe distanze,
quando le navi all'orizzonte scendevano
invece di sparire all'improvviso
perché la Terra finiva,
per cui quando la nostra
'bolla' di vita si è estesa
è cambiata anche la nostra
concezione della realtà,
e ci siamo resi conto che
siamo esseri solidi superiori.
Che viviamo in tre dimensioni.
Allora, che cosa si può
fare in tre dimensioni
che i poveri abitanti di Flatland
non possono fare?
Due cose: una cosa ha
un nome strano 'K3,3'
ed è questo oggetto qui
questo oggetto qui non si
può fare a due dimensioni.
Il povero quadrato non
lo può fare, noi sì.
Allora che cos'è questa
interconnessione, se volete,
questa specie di rete?
Più o meno è il principio
del tavolo della sagra,
o il tavolo da matrimonio, qualsiasi cosa.
Vi sarà capitato:
siete al tavolo, avete due
persone di lato, tre davanti,
vi può andar bene come
vi può andar male.
Però non riuscite a tenere,
il vostro micromondo sono cinque persone,
ed è piatto il vostro micromondo, ok?
Non riuscite a parlare
contemporaneamente, a interagire
con tutte le persone che
stanno nel vostro micromondo,
tant'è che vi può andar male.
Questo è un limite.
Nel mondo piatto del tavolone della sagra,
siamo più o meno come
il quadrato di Flatland.
Un'altra cosa che non si può fare
- sono due, queste cose - è quest'altro
oggetto che si chiama K5.
Ve lo sintetizzo: essenzialmente,
pensate al brindisi.
Il brindisi che la gente fa,
cosa c'è di più bello?
Non si può fare un brindisi all'unisono,
cioè che nello stesso
momento i bicchieri tintinnano
con più di altri tre bicchieri.
Provateci: se ci riuscite
non - vincete il Nobel,
oppure siete su un'altra dimensione.
Non si può, perché è
sempre qualcosa di vincolato
al mondo delle due dimensioni.
Non potete rovesciare il bicchiere.
Per cui non siamo mica
tanto superiori forse, no?
Razza solida?
Beh, ci avete mai pensato?
Potete dire,
chi se ne frega
dei bicchieri e del tavolone della sagra,
poi mi alzo, o non brindo più.
Beh, mica tanto: questa è
vita di tutti i giorni, giusto?
E qui cosa sta succedendo?
Sta succedendo qualcosa di mica bello.
Queste cose sono i nostri
legami, le nostre catene
con il mondo piatto che ci attanaglia.
Ogni volta che vedete un semaforo,
pensate a quanto spazio
c'è, a quanto spazio c'è sopra:
eppure siamo lì fermi
davanti al semaforo, ok?
Per cui questa è la nostra tenaglia
al mondo delle due dimensioni.
Notate anche la forma
dei segnali stradali che ci siamo scelti
che è tristemente simile
agli abitanti di Flatland,
per cui tutto torna, alla fine.
Per cui altro che esseri superiori, no?
Abbiamo un po' po' di
cervello, siamo esseri senzienti:
non riusciamo a fare
nulla di meglio
che essere fermi al semaforo o in coda?
Beh, sì che riusciamo.
Per esempio, quando si è
cominciato nel nostro passato
a cercare di superare questo
problema della terra piatta:
pensate anche solo ai ponti.
C'è una frattura nel mondo piatto, no?
Fiumi o altre strade oppure
case - e c'è un ponte,
un ponte che sfrutta la terza dimensione.
Questa cosa qui gli abitanti di Flatland
non possono farla, noi sì.
E poi cosa abbiamo fatto?
Abbiamo preso la terza
dimensione nel volo,
siamo riusciti a volare,
per cui è bellissimo: siamo riusciti
a elevarci e a diventare
esseri a tre dimensioni.
Però il progresso non si è fermato lì.
Sapete cos'è successo: telefoni,
cellulari, Internet, Facebook.
E allora, dove stiamo andando?
Qual è il significato di tutto questo?
Così, succedono queste
cose perché sono belle?
No, pensiamoci un attimo.
Quando qualcosa come
il telefono nasce, come nasce il ponte,
succede qualche cosa,
la nostra 'bolla' si espande,
la nostra 'bolla' fisica si espande,
riusciamo a raggiungere sempre
più terreno, in questo caso,
e accade una cosa molto particolare:
c'è un cammino che prima era lungo,
come questo rosso,
all'improvviso ha
una scorciatoia, una nuova scorciatoia
come il telefono.
Quando telefonate, non dovete
più prendere l'auto,
subire semafori e così via, ok?
Si crea una scorciatoia.
Questa scorciatoia non è nient'altro
che un buco dimensionale.
Cioè, quello che sta succedendo è
che uno spazio ha una sua dimensione,
come può essere la nostra terra piatta,
e a un certo momento le scorciatoie
cominciano a aumentare
la dimensionalità di questo spazio,
cioè da uno spazio piatto si passa
a qualcosa di più ricco.
È lo stesso principio
dei salti nell'iperspazio
di cui avete visto in tanti
romanzi di fantascienza.
La stessa identica cosa succede poi
col prosieguo delle tecnologie:
che razza di progresso capita
quando nascono i cellulari?
Succede che queste dimensioni aumentano.
Quando Internet viene introdotta,
la dimensione del nostro spazio
aumenta, cioè da due dimensioni
aumenta l'efficienza e se
non proprio a tre dimensioni
diventa qualcosa di più ricco
delle due dimensioni piatte
a cui siamo abituati.
La stessa cosa con Facebook,
non è diverso.
Le connessioni che si
creano tramite Facebook
aumentano la dimensionalità
del nostro spazio,
cioè da due dimensioni
lo spazio si sta accartocciando:
quante più scorciatoie ci sono,
detto molto intuitivamente,
tanto più le cose migliorano.
Motore di ricerca: cos'è
un motore di ricerca?
Va bene, metto la query, scrivo
e mi arrivano le risposte;
però in realtà il motore di ricerca
è un accartocciatore di spazio,
e il bello è che si possono
misurare queste cose, no?
Io ho solo quattro minuti scarsi
ora per concludere,
[ma] si possono misurare,
per cui cose come Google
accartocciano lo spazio in cui viviamo,
sia lo spazio fisico ma anche
lo spazio informativo,
e in una maniera del tutto simile
agli accartocciamenti che
vengono creati da Facebook
e che sono stati creati prima
per quasi tutte le altre tecnologie
che abbiamo visto.
Questo è un esempio di
accartocciamento al massimo grado,
è bellissimo questo sistema.
Ha un potenziale quasi pari
alle tre dimensioni piene.
Sapete cos'è questo pezzettino?
Questo pezzettino
di accartocciamento spinto
è un pezzetto del nostro cervello.
Il nostro cervello è l'esempio
di accartocciamento al massimo grado,
cioè riesce quasi a raggiungere
la dimensionalità piena,
le tre dimensioni piene.
Pensate al potenziale, quindi:
quando quasi si raggiungono
le tre dimensioni,
ecco dove si arriva.
Si crea la coscienza, si crea
una potenzialità superiore.
Dove siamo ora?
Beh, in quasi tutti i sistemi
che abbiamo visto finora,
incluse anche le amicizie di Facebook,
l'accartocciamento dovuto a Google,
la rete telefonica e altro,
per ora siamo al grado di evoluzione,
come accartocciamento -
l'efficienza del sistema, se volete,
è pari a quella di un verme,
di questo verme qui che è uno
dei più semplici al mondo,
si chiama C. Elegans.
Per cui ora, nel grado
dell'evoluzione siamo qui,
siamo più o meno al verme -
però insomma
abbiamo fatto dei bei progressi
dai nostri antenati.
E tutto questo non è solo tecnologia,
perché la tecnologia
senza società non esiste.
C'è questa scritta che campeggia in giro,
Meno Internet più Cabernet.
Meno tecnologia, più società.
Bella cosa, però non è totalmente vera.
Cioè quello che succede, quando beviamo, è
che tanto più beviamo, paradossalmente,
tanti più soldi alla fine guadagniamo.
O meglio, in media,
se bevete di più guadagnate più soldi.
E perché diavolo succede questo?
Non perché vi vengono idee
meravigliose con l'alcool.
Ma perché
quando bevete con qualcuno
state creando una connessione,
si crea una scintilla,
e quella scintilla va
ad aggiungersi, quel link,
a tutti gli altri link che fanno
parte della vostra vita
sia dal lato fisico
che dal lato tecnologico,
per cui astratto, dell'informazione.
E la vostra rete aumenta,
e il vostro spazio sta
aumentando di dimensionalità.
Per cui non c'è una vera distinzione
tra reale e virtuale,
tra mondo fisico e mondo
astratto dell'informazione.
Sono le due facce della stessa medaglia,
perché sono unite in questa
rete di accartocciamenti,
se volete in questo grande
cervello fatto da connessioni.
E la prova - nel caso
del vino, per esempio -
la potevate notare anche direttamente.
Second life: mondo virtuale,
estremamente virtuale.
È successo è che la gente
comprava drink virtuali.
Un drink virtuale è un blocco
di pixel che qui vedete
solo per fare questo, cioè
per brindare, per bere assieme
dentro a Second Life, ok?
Perché quello che conta è la scintilla.
Non è veramente l'alcol,
l'alcol non conta nulla.
Per cui la morale qual è?
Dove stiamo andando?
Qui termino, perché purtroppo
il tempo sta finendo.
Stiamo andando in questa direzione,
cioè col giusto paio di occhiali,
la nostra realtàva vista
in un certo modo.
Chi siamo, da dove veniamo
e dove stiamo andando.
Il quadrato aveva ragione.
Stiamo andando, tutte
le tecnologie di successo
stanno andando verso
l'accartocciamento del nostro mondo,
cioè la nostra rete di
conoscenze da due dimensioni,
spazio piatto, si sta accartocciando
fino a tendere a un sistema
con sempre più dimensioni.
Per cui posso dirvi
di non pensare a due dimensioni,
ma fate come il quadrato.
Pensate a più dimensioni,
perché quello è il nostro futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)